It was your father's last wish
that you dig his grave.
What?
♪♪
(Knock-knock)
(Door opens)
Our father is dead.
His last wish was that his sons
attend his funeral.
Ray:
You don't have to go.
He's dead.
He'll never know.
You are a very tender man.
You know that?
♪♪
Mendes:
Okay. Your father's last will.
It was his wish that you dig his
grave.
♪♪
What?
Raymond:
The old man was always screwing
with us.
But, forgiveness is good.
♪♪
I want to show you the casket
that your father pre-selected.
♪♪
The cheapest man who ever lived.
Hi.
Raymond:
How did you know our father?
♪♪
We were lovers for a while.
What was he like as a father?
The worst.
(Arguing)
Ray:
Like a weight on my chest.
♪♪
Raymond:
Forgiveness is good.
(Inhales)
Hi, guys. This is my son, Simon.
Lucia:
Raymond and Ray.
Your brothers.
Hello.
Hi.
♪♪
Raymond:
We come from chaos.
♪♪
Our father was a monster. We
repeat. We repeat.
We don’t have to.
(Plays trumpet)
♪I'm going through changes♪
Ray:
Growing up, my brother and I, we
were connected at the hip.
♪♪
And then just being near each
other is a reminder of all that
pain.
♪Oh, in my life♪
I want to know what it feels
like,
Raymond:
letting it go.
♪♪
Raymond:
But I'm scared it's gonna crush
me.
♪♪
Raymond:
(Yelling)
♪♪
Raymond:
Come with me.
Ray:
Okay.
But, it's gonna take a whole lot
more than a hole in the ground
to get the old man out of your head.
♪♪